I'm smoking I've got a raging quack
addiction you know I'm separated from my
daughter I'm in a Venezuelan prison
where people are getting killed all
around me where I have to face the next
10 years of my life and yeah I took an
overdose
hi and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives the podcast from
that Bible we are joined here today by
Natalie Welsh welcome Natalie hi thank
you van and uh for anyone who isn't
aware of who you are could you just give
a brief introduction yeah I'm author of
the book Escape from Venezuela's
deadliest prison which is available on
Amazon which as it says in the title
it's um my biography about my time and
incarceration in a jail in Venezuela
where I got caught drug smuggling in the
year 2001 and my subsequent escape from
from there fantastic
um that book title is one of those ones
that you don't need to do any work do
you it's just sells it says it's gonna
says it in the title yeah okay well I'm
excited to hear all about it um but in
terms of you as a person why don't we
sort of go back to the beginning and
sort of learn a little bit about how you
ended up in that situation so what was
childhood like for you
um I had a pretty difficult childhood
um my mom and dad had split up
um before I was born
so my mum had a new partner
um so I bought it by my stepdad and
um he was a bully really and
it was difficult and there was a lot of
physical and mental abuse involved
so
naturally I I think you know it's that
naturally leads on to rebellion and
misbehavior and conflict and
um
I got put into a children's home
which was just so unruly
um it was just chaos what age was this I
was
like 12 or 13 when I got put in the
Children's Home and there were
about another
30 kids there I think so it was like 30
other children there from the ages of
like 9 to 16. oh wow all with whatever
issues going on because that's why
they're in their children's home
um and it was just Mayhem and Chaos so
then again that just kind of leads to
more
um Rebellion I think did you do you
remember feeling
did you understand why you were there
like did you know that you'd done a
series of events that meant you were
there and you were like well I did it or
was it was there a sense of sort of
anger and frustration and confusion um
it was relief oh I was relieved yeah
because
um it meant that I wasn't in the family
home and it meant that I wasn't getting
abused and bullied by my stepdad so um
the police came and put me in the
children's home right so when I was put
in there it was just total
relief because I was always walking on
eggshells at home all the time I never
knew what was going to trigger
um my stepdad so it was just a really
volatile nervous environment to be in so
to go from that into this children's
home where it was just everybody was
just doing what they wanted there was no
kind of consequences to anything it was
from one end of the scale to the
complete opposite end of the scale there
was no kind of in-between on on the
journey right so you'd imagine as
someone on the outside you'd imagine the
Children's Home was designed to give you
some sort of structure or something like
that but was it the opposite complete
opposite yeah
um I think from what I can understand
now those kind of Children's Home that I
was in they don't exist anymore I think
they either encouraged like foster home
placements okay or there's just kind of
like temporary accommodation for young
adults with like support workers but the
environment that I was in I think that's
definitely kind of been like eradication
sit down I think they've looked back on
that and seen that it doesn't work and
how long did you stay in there for until
I was 16 years old so 12 to 16. yeah and
what was life like in there like how did
it start to shape how your life would
progress after leaving
um
well whilst I was in there
um I
start I had a relationship with my
social worker oh wow which was he was
supposed to be in charge of
I don't know like he was my key worker
so he's supposed to be in charge of
um guiding me into adulthood and so how
old were you at that point 14 15 and how
old was he
older than that right yeah yeah he's in
his 30s oh God yeah so in a legal
relationship yeah okay yeah wow yeah and
then I went on and had it we've got a
child together okay got my doses from
him yeah so that kind of really messed
my head up as well because I was I was
already messed up yeah then entered into
this relationship that went on for quite
a while and he was married with kids and
so it was just do you mind me asking I
don't want to if you don't answer it's
fine I don't want to cry but it's your
relationship with him like when you look
back on that relationship do you see it
as a relationship or do you see him as a
predator
I see that he was in a position of power
yeah that
he abused like
um
I don't know if I'd say Predator
um but I think that he should have
recognized that I was a messed up kid
yeah that had a history of
unhealthy relationships with older men
um and he should have
reacted and responded differently and
instead of encouraging and entertaining
this
um relationship at the time I didn't see
anything I thought that I was in love
with him maybe I was in love with him or
infatuated or maybe I was looking for
this fatherly figure or I just wanted to
feel love you know and but when I look
back on it now then I understand that on
every level
um it it shouldn't have happened yeah
um yeah I can see it's a very complex
situation because you have a daughter
now relationship what what age did you
get pregnant 16 16 right yeah so people
do you think people were aware that that
relationship was ongoing uh he lost his
job for him right okay yeah eventually
okay well okay so what happened at that
point when you got pregnant
so I think I'd I'd left the children's
home so I left the Children's Home on my
16th birthday oh and then
went into my own accommodation
got pregnant at 16.
um and I think I thought oh so the
pregnancy was after you left again so it
was just after okay but you continued
the relationship yeah okay yeah it was
just after and I think you know I
thought that we were going to be
together and we were going to have been
happy families and you know none of that
happened and it was a struggle because
I was a single parent basically you know
he would
occasionally show up but and I didn't
get hot you know much family support at
all like hardly anything from my mum and
so um and I didn't really know what I
was doing and
um and I thought I knew everything you
know as you do I think as any 16 year
old probably does and I really battled
with it and uh and it was a real
struggle
I mean I can't imagine what I was like
because
I think how my my child was born when I
was late 30s and I found it very hard as
someone who had a lot of life experience
so being a 16 year old in quite an
unusual
circumstance
it must have been really hard yeah I
mean
I think I felt
I thought I was so grown up I think
because of what I'd gone through from an
early age in life and because of living
in the Children's Home and kind of like
fending for myself and I think I just
felt like I was a a grown-up and like I
said like I knew it all and really I was
just a child inside and I wasn't ready
for for what was about to come okay well
let's talk about that what was about to
come how did it progress from moving
into that flat with her with her baby
what was the next step
so
um I was experimenting I mean I'd been
experimenting with drugs when I think I
started about
14 years old in the children's home I
started experimenting with drugs with
amphetamines and ecstasying
and then there was kind of like a a
natural progression then
um and cocaine and then I was living in
my flat with my daughter
and I had like this group of friends
which I felt like this um
I felt like I was doing the things I was
supposed to be doing finally you know I
was 16 17 years old and I had these
group of friends that were age age
appropriate and we were going out to you
know bars and parties and rivers and
just doing the things that you're
supposed to be doing at that age and it
was the first kind of time in my life
that I'd felt that I fitted in and I was
really happy and
that
um all went wrong and
um I had I'd split it with
um my daughter's dad by this point and
uh had a boyfriend in this group of
friends and we split up and because they
were kind of like his friends I felt
myself I found myself like just isolated
again
um and it was just heartbreaking for me
I really struggled to to deal with that
to suddenly go from having you know
being in the center of something to
suddenly just being like on my own
um I wasn't mentally prepared for it at
all and in the
Village that I was living in at the time
there was a huge
um presence of track of crack dealers
he'd come over from Jamaica and set up
like bases all over the place you know
they're probably like three kind of
flats that were working 24 hours a day
that had people that had been you know
coming over from Jamaica specifically to
work these flats and that's just in the
area that I was in and then what year
was this this was like
19 hang on
1999 okay yeah it was around 1999
um and there was a a girl in specific
that kind of
recruited me I'm not blaming her you
know because I made my own choices and I
made the decisions to
do what I started doing but it was
heavily influenced by this girl that was
coming around
um the and bringing drugs around like
the the drug dealers were giving her
drugs and then she was coming around and
feeding me these drugs like for free
um and just got me hooked so quickly
like literally within like a week I
think what kind of drugs crack cocaine
right okay yeah crack cocaine and it
just completely ruined me I was already
broken anyway and then I found like this
I don't know community and some kind of
escapism I think in the in the drug but
it's just so fake and false and
temporary but it was too late I was just
completely consumed by it and at that
point I guess the job had been done in
terms of giving you free drugs because
now you wanted drugs that you had to
yeah pay for it yeah yeah as soon as I
got I remember I remember it so clearly
um I was on benefits at the time
and I remember that I was being given
these drugs all the time and I said oh
when I get my benefits you know I
thought you out and I got my benefits
and I spent it all like instantly within
a couple of hours of getting it I'd
spent it all on crack and I had no food
no gas no electric
um and that's how my life then continued
for the next three years you know and
trying to kid myself every time well I
didn't know that was silly I shouldn't
have done that
um hating on myself really chastising
myself and hating on myself but then
doing exactly the same thing and are you
raising a child at this point trying to
yeah not very well but did you have any
support for that with the the father's
side or anything not from the father no
um I was really lucky that I had support
from a from a friend right who
she recognized what was going on
so from there
um I started committing crime which is
just again a natural progression of of
being a drug addict
um and then
I got offered
an opportunity or got asked if I wanted
to to go away and and smuggle some drugs
and was up by the people you were buying
it from yeah so were they doing it as a
kind of instead of paying you can do
this and we'll give you some more well
no they offered to pay me like uh yeah
they said you want to go to you know
this place you want to go and get some
jokes and you know we'll pay you this
amount of money
and What attracted to it me to it more
than anything it wasn't the money it was
getting away from the environment that I
was in like my
brain like was so messed up I thought
that it would be an opportunity to get
to get clean even though I'm going to go
and get a suitcase full of the very
poison that's killing me I thought well
I can go there and I can get away from
this place all I need to do is get away
from from here and break these like
habits in this cycle and get away from
these people so I thought I can I could
go there I can go and do that trip I can
get clean and then I can come back with
the drugs and I'll be clean and I'll
have many and I just won't do it when I
come back okay you know that was the I
think that's how I Justified it to
myself in in my head but can you talk us
through that first trip then the the
first experience of
transporting drugs yeah well the first
time
um
it didn't go to plan so I went to
Jamaica and then
um
when I got there
I was quite I was really lonely actually
because I've gone from I was just in a
country where you know I didn't know
anybody I was kind of left
on my own but it was an opportunity to
you know I was not smoking drugs
so I kind of
I think I kidded myself into thinking
you know when I get back
that's it you know I thought I was clean
um but whilst I was there
um the person that I was working for
told me not to bring anything back
because
they'd been told somebody knew that I'd
gone there and they'd been told that the
police were going to be waiting for me
like expecting me
um at the airport or when I got back so
I didn't actually bring anything back
the the first time
so I got a free trip there and did they
still pay you no right and were they
angry at you or yeah yeah they were
really angry with me oh but what what
had you done wrong I said something I
told somebody that I was going okay and
that person had then like told a rival
gang okay then it was the rival gang
then that had been in contact and said
and were the police waiting when you got
back yeah yeah I got torn apart at the
airport oh wow yeah so if you had
brought something back you would have
been yeah they would have totally got me
right okay yeah wow you would have
thought that should have been enough to
put me off yes
okay you know and and how much would
they pay you for a trip like what was
the offer to do that four thousand
pounds wow which 90s
it probably seemed like a lot of money
in the position that I was in it seemed
like a lot of money yeah relevant to
what I was doing the risk I'm taking and
relevant to how much money they're
making
um it's peanuts okay I didn't understand
any of that four thousand pounds just so
it was a lot it sounded like a lot of
money to me so the first one has gone
wrong yeah they're annoyed at you
obviously you'd had a bit of a shock
yeah
um
a lot of people I think would have gone
got off lucky there let's stop but you
continued with the same guy no I did it
with a different gang at this time okay
so the first one went wrong and then
there was a couple of success a few
successful ones yeah and then the one
that we're gonna get to is the one that
went catastrophically wrong yeah
um so how did that come about the
Venezuela trip so I'd done the the
successful ones to Holland
um and then every time I'd been
doing these trips I'd been connected
there was like a
small team of people that were kind of
in charge of like looking after me you
know so he picked me up from the train
station I'd stay with them like kind of
mind us really
um and two of them who I'd met like a
few times now they did this regularly or
so well they said that they'd done this
regularly and they were Smugglers and
I'd stay at their houses in you know in
London and it was really nice houses it
was really nice furniture and they were
dressed really well and they had really
nice clothes and I wanted that life
um I don't know if that was part of
their role was to you know enamor me
with the with the lifestyle again I
wasn't thinking about consequences I
wasn't thinking about
the damage that the drugs even though I
you know obviously I knew firsthand
because I was a victim myself but I I
wasn't thinking of anybody else I was
just thinking you know it's really
selfish
um thought process that I was going
through and I saw this life that these
other Smugglers had and I thought I you
know I want some of that you know I'm
fed up of my shitty life which I've had
most of my life I want a good life I
want some money and I want a nice house
I Want to Be Drug Free and at the time
were they drug-free yeah they weren't
users no not at all and at the time
for me that was that was kind of my my
ticket you know I would that I was
looking for
okay so they set up this trip to
Venezuela for you yeah
um what drug was it that you were
cocaine cocaine and it was it you were
taking it or you're going to collect it
and bring it back I was collecting it
and bringing it and bringing it back
yeah and am I right in thinking that on
this trip I mean maybe this is what you
did before but this trip was different
because you took your daughter didn't
you yeah yeah yeah so where did that
decision come into it
um
I was I was told to she'd come with me
on the on my other trip oh okay she had
been she had been with me
um and by now I'm building up my
confidence as well you know the the
Jamaican thing they told me they said
don't bring anything back so I think I
was always thought now right if
anything's going to go wrong and they're
going to tell me don't bring anything
back
the the Dutch trips had gone
successfully
um I had these people telling me you
know bring your daughter it's all part
of you know the plan no one's going to
think that you're smuggling drugs when
you've got your daughter with you I was
told that everything had been arranged
that everybody had been paid off that
the Guardia in the in Venezuela had been
paid off and that people in Claudius
Venezuelan police yeah yeah yeah like
the national Army right that they'd been
um paid off
um that the airport staff had been paid
off you know I was under the impression
that it was just going to be plain
sailing
um and even more plain sailing you know
with my daughter and also
um because the
I wonder I kind of wonder sometimes if
the the girl like the the other girl
that was a Smuggler that would like you
to take me in and stuff I kind of wonder
sometimes if she
knew what they were going to do because
she offered she said when I was going
you know oh you know leave like at the
last minute she was like oh you know you
could leave your daughter here and I'll
look after her and I was like no no
because I don't really know you I can't
just use my daughter she was a stranger
my daughter's not going to know what's
going on and you know anyway everybody
else has everyone's told me that it's
all part of the plan and I think I
wonder if she if she knew so yeah I mean
that sounds that's a big Cliffhanger
there so what what did they have planned
what happened in that trip well it's
Rich you know what as well when I was at
the airport
when I was go first of all we missed the
first flight we were supposed to my boss
came with me which was odd
so he came with me to Amsterdam I flew
from Amsterdam and we missed the first
flight and then we got like the next
flight I think it was like a week later
and I was sat at the airport and
I had this just awful feeling come over
me
which I now recognize as Instinct at the
time I again I did just knew nothing
about I just had this my stomach was
going and this feeding of dreads and
just the closer and closer it got to
going just everything just felt so wrong
in every level
but again I didn't know how to interpret
that and I said to my boss I said I've
got a really funny feeling about this
and he said to me don't worry about it
then that's you know don't go
um and I wanted to
impress him I thought I was just being
you know chicken [__] again all kinds of
stupid
um thoughts going through my head and I
just completely pushed that feeling
aside when it's almost like the universe
was screaming at me you know to not go
and I just
didn't know how to interpret those
feelings at that time so I just ignored
them and and and got on the plane
um
again kind of being
reassured that everything would be all
right because everybody had been you
know paid off
okay
so then you arrive yeah you decide yeah
and when did things start to go when did
you realize something was wrong hmm
I think
I think I should have known
I think I knew the whole time
of the Instinct yeah yeah I think I knew
the whole I think I knew the whole time
and again it was just this
naive belief of invincibility yeah that
I had
um you see early 20s here 21 21 yeah
yeah I was 21.
um because
nothing went to plan nothing went as as
I was told it was going to go there was
nobody waiting for me at the airport I
was expecting for there to be someone to
be waiting for me at the airport I was
expecting to be taken to my hotel I
thought whilst I was there that
um I was gonna be
kind of minded and taken out and show
for different not chauffeur driven
around but you know taken around and
looked after like what had happened when
I'd been in Holland working for this
team you know I'd been looked after and
that didn't happen I was just like
abandoned from from the from the get-go
I was just completely kind of um
abandoned there was nobody waiting at
the airport I was really confused I
didn't know what was going on
um I had to phone my boss up that was in
London he seemed confused that there was
no one there waiting for me
gave me instructions on what to do
got to my got to my um hotel and then
the guy the connection at that end came
to see me like the next day I wasn't
impressed with him like at all he told
me to like wait in my room for him or in
my Chalet which I didn't do because it's
boiling hot and I've got a you know a
three-year-old with me that wants to go
out in the swimming pool and this guy's
telling me to wait there and then he
picked me up and
really didn't treat me very well
compared to what I was used to and then
just abandoned me again until like the
it was like the day before I was leaving
which I wasn't expecting so I didn't
like him I didn't have a good feeling
about him and the
when I got there when I received a
suitcase
and it was a day before my plane it's
just it stank so much of glue like I
could really smell like they'd obviously
just like glued it and I left the
suitcase open I called night and I'd go
out and I'd go in my come back into my
Chalet and just the smell of the glue
would just hit me straight away and I
was like I'm sure this isn't supposed to
so what was the glue what have they done
with the glue they'd um they'd created a
false bottom suitcase so like um like a
hidden compartment right so the suitcase
was like that big but really it was only
like that big and then they had this
like compartment underneath so they'd
like ripped out put the drugs in there
and then just like you know glued it all
and that's what stank and that's what
stank was was this glue
um and the guy was just convincing me he
was like no it's you know it's fine you
know it's in your head and
obviously it wasn't but I think again
because I was just
I was out of my league I didn't know
what I was doing
um
and I think I'd set these wheels in
motion and I was kind of on this roller
coaster now that I felt that I couldn't
get off yeah and I could have done at
any point all right it's Connor here one
of The Producers on extraordinary lives
that led Bible which is going to take a
short break from the show to talk about
our sponsor nordvpn now I'm a really big
fan of nordvpn and I use it loads when I
travel as much as I love getting some
sun I also want to keep up with my
favorite shows from back home and no VPN
lets you do that and it's so quick and
easy to use to give you an idea recently
I was in Colombia and I was able to
watch the finale of succession whilst
relaxing by the pool pure Bliss and
because of nordvpn's threat protection I
was able to do this using my hotel's
free public Wi-Fi with absolute Peace of
Mind extraordinary lives listeners can
get an exclusive nordvpn deal with a
huge discount by going to nordvpn.com
forward slash minutes and it's risk-free
with nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
you'll also get an additional bonus
month by going through nordvpn.com
forward slash minutes and this this
amazing deal is included on all plans
standard plus and complete again you can
get it now by going to nordvpn.com
forward slash minutes that's nordvpn.com
forward slash minutes so you get to the
airport yeah the suitcase yeah you still
smell it while you're walking through
the air I think I can yeah I don't know
if I really can but it's in your head
yeah but it's totally in my head now and
then what happened so
put the suitcase through I'm definitely
paranoid we're handing the suitcase in
like when I've got to go and check the
suitcase in to the on the
um gate I'm like 100 convinced that the
woman can smell the suitcase but now I'm
just reminding myself the whole time
that it's okay like they're all in on it
like it doesn't matter if she can smell
the suitcase or she's been paid because
everybody yeah you know she's been paid
you know the National Guards have been
paid you know everybody's in on it now
so it doesn't this is what I'm saying to
myself you know it doesn't matter
because they've been paid off and then I
go through to departures
and I'm sat down with my daughter and
next to me there's a table with a family
sat down there's a husband and wife and
a couple of kids
and I see the the the god the guards
come in and they go up to this table and
they're asking them for ID and I just I
knew instantly that it was not them that
they were looking for I knew that it was
me I did this just everything I was like
they're looking for me so they showed
them their ID they came over to me
asked me to show them my passport which
I did and then they asked me to go with
them
so I'm just saying to myself this is
okay this is part of the plan you know
kidding myself really
um you're not worried yet still yeah I
am I think I'm just refusing yeah okay
yeah I think so holding it at Bay yeah
yeah but I'm just having to I'm just
saying to myself like
I think you would I think anybody would
until that actual moment of no return
that you're just going to say to
yourself it's okay you know when you're
a kid when you're really young and maybe
you've done something wrong and you just
think that if you like squeeze your eyes
like hard enough or you know that when
you go to sleep you know and you're
gonna wake up and you can reverse time
you know until you actually realize that
that can't happen that's where I was at
that you know just like it's not it's
gonna be fine it's going to be fun like
that childish yeah um belief that you
know everything could be all right if
you're just weld it enough
and um
yeah so they took me into a room
and my suitcase was on the table
so I'm still trying to justify it to
myself I'm saying right okay they're
just checking that they've got the right
suitcase that's what they're doing you
know I was told that the guardian knew I
was told that they might pull me to one
side they're just checking that you know
they've got the right suitcase and
they're letting the right person through
um
and deep down inside I knew that it
wasn't but I just wasn't
ready to accept that then at that point
and then
yeah so they asked me to confirm it as
my suitcase
and then they opened up my suitcase
and then they pulled out a knife and I'm
like I'm sure this isn't supposed to be
like I'm pretty sure this bit isn't
supposed to be happening you know that
that's what I'm just starting to kind of
maybe potentially acknowledge that
things aren't going the way that they're
supposed to be going
so then they put
you know the knife into the suitcase and
bring the knife out and you know it's
got the drugs on it
I'm like yeah that's definitely not
supposed to be happening
um
but I still I still
kind of wouldn't refuse to accept that I
was really excuse my language that's
fine yeah
um
I still thought that I might get on my
plane
I don't know I thought well they might
just say well we're keeping this off you
go yeah right because I was you know
British and they'd say right you know I
don't do it again yeah you know they
would just literally give me a sap on
the wrist and tell me that you know I
can't do that and I keep in a suitcase
and you know so I'm like watching the
clock you know still hoping that I'm
gonna get get my plane
and they bring in um somebody from the
airline to
translate because this is all going on
in Spanish yeah and I don't understand a
word of of Spanish but I understand that
I'm not in a very good position here and
this is not how things are supposed to
be going so the woman from the airline
comes in that they've used to translate
um and she
pretty much tells me that um I'm not
going to be getting on my plane and that
I'm going to be going to prison for 10
years wow Mitch just tells you that then
yeah it's a straight away yeah
um and I didn't believe her yeah or I
didn't want to believe her I just
thought that she was trying to frighten
me and it was just a little scared
tactic and that I'd get on the next
plane because
what else were they gonna do with me and
you've got your daughter there I've got
my daughter exactly so what else are
they gonna do
so then they put me in contact with my
um with a consulate
who tells me exactly the same thing like
there's it has a zero sympathy
over the phone at all and tells me quite
matter if factly that this is what's
going to happen you know you're gonna
get arrested you're gonna get taken to
the police station you're gonna have
your
um daughter taken away from you and
you're gonna go to prison for 10 years
oh my God yeah and I still do and I and
I still
didn't believe them do you think it
might have been shock at that point I
think so yeah yeah I went it was about a
year before it was about a year before I
actually finally believed that this is
it now that I've actually was I did have
a you know a 10-year prison sentence and
I was supposed to be in jail for ten
years so it was a no trial was it just
what you yeah no there was a trial well
I don't know if I don't know there was a
court proceeding yeah yeah but it was
already decided yeah well apparently I
pleaded guilty
so oh I didn't have a clue what was
going on it was all in Spanish I had
like I had an interpreter
that couldn't speak English it was like
the most brokening it was the worst
English ever I'd like how he got a job
as a interpreter in a in a Venezuelan
court of law I have no idea there must
have been some backhand there included
in that because it was just
I may as well have not had him
um
and then when I got sentenced because I
didn't get sentenced straight away I was
in a police station for a few months
um and then when I actually got a
sentence I'd been transferred to there
to the prison and I'd gone back to the
prison and I had all this paperwork with
me
and but I knew what was going to happen
like by that point I I knew that I was
going to get a sentence to 10 years so
you know it didn't matter they could
have done the court case in Chinese yeah
like I knew what the outcome was was
going to be and was it 10 years because
of the amount of drugs he'd been caught
with who did that automatically mean 10
years except over there it's any of mine
is oh wow yeah there were some English
people there were two English guys in
the prison that I was in
um and they'd been caught with like tens
of they've been caught with a container
ship full of cocaine and they got 10
years oh yeah how much did you have five
kilos well five kilos but it was three
kilos by the time I went to court oh
really yeah a couple of kilos went
missing along the way oh wow yeah it's
pretty bog standard I think over there
that's sort of an interesting
I mean at that point you may as well do
a ton if you're going to get caught for
five right if you're gonna get the same
amount of time yeah five kilos or it's
just ten years it's just a standard
whether you get caught with weed coke oh
wow like a bit on the street or you know
a bit in a suitcase or a ship full of it
it's just like a mandatory 10 years so
what happened during this period of the
of the kind of like the the
the court proceeding and all that kind
of thing what happened where was your
daughter
so we spent the first night together
um in a
what they didn't know what to do with me
really because I had my daughter they
were really kind of like confused on
what to do with me so I spent a night in
a
Guardia station I was like handcuffed
chained to like this like a water pipe
um and my daughter was with me and
at that point my
concern or my priority was to try and
keep her calm like to for her to you
know not to Panic or be just draw or
upset and just try and did you
understand vaguely what was happening
really no did she know something bad was
happening or not even there okay no she
didn't she didn't understand what was
going on and she was calm because I I
made I was like oh you know there was
because she was in the room when they
took me into the room with a suitcase
she was in the room and she was like
asking why you know what was they were
doing the suitcase and what was that in
the suitcase and I was just lying
through my teeth to her you know to just
say oh you know there's some big stones
in there and they shouldn't be in there
and and we're just going to go here and
just trying to answer her questions and
to not freak her out and panic her and
um she just
you know believed everything I said of
course because I'm I'm her mum and went
along with her so she stayed with me the
first night
and then the next day I got taken
just like all these different police
stations I had to have like fingerprints
done and then
um there was somewhere where the
suitcase was where they'd leave the
suitcase out with all the parcels out on
the on the floor and then
um I got taken to
I think I got taken
gosh I can't remember where
I got separated from
Nikita
I can't remember if it was in a police
station or at a court where somebody
came along and said that
um
I was going to be taken to a police
station and that Nikita was going to be
taken and and put
into a orphanage I think it was war in
Venezuela Venezuela yeah whilst
um Arrangements were made for her to
um go back to
to the UK
that must been heard it really was and
I'm talking about it now
it might seem like with no emotion but
I've had to process of 20 years ago
nearly 20 years ago now like well this
actual moment was over 20 years ago and
I've talked about this so many times and
processed this and had to forgive myself
that it's not that there's no emotion
it's that
I can't beat myself up for the rest of
my life because I've done that and I've
gone through that and it doesn't change
anything like I know what an awful thing
I did and I can't turn back time and
there's nothing I can do to change that
and if I chastise myself for the rest of
my life that's not healthy for me that's
not healthy for my relationship with my
daughter so she's forgiven me
um which is the most important thing for
me
um and I've through a lot of work I've
forgiven myself so I'm not emotionless
about it I've just had to move on from
that because it took me
so long before I could even speak about
it without breaking down into tears for
feeling like such an awful person
but
I can't change what I did you know so I
have to just move on from that
okay so she she was
um taken and then you were what was the
point then how long was it from the
point that she was taken off you
that you were then
taken to a prison
um I got to a police station actually
um she was taken off me
and I got put into like a police station
a holding
kind of holding police station
um
but it was mental I'd never
in a million years would imagine that it
could be anything like that it's the
holding station yeah
um
like I thought there was a thing like
human rights that existed all over the
world they do not exist in Venezuela and
I think I thought that because I was
British then I had a British Embassy I
just assumed that I would be exempt from
right you know Venezuelan conditions and
then my Embassy would look after me and
I had all these rights and no that's
yeah there's not at all they you know no
way
um so I got taken to the police station
and I got put into this
room it was a tiny holding cell and
there must have been 20 odd women in
there
big scary
Spanish-speaking Venezuelan women
um it was stinky it was sweaty it was
vile
um it was there was like this horrible
fluorescent like light in there
um I didn't understand a word that
anyone was saying it was overcrowded it
was it was horrendous there was um
like a sinkhole in the in the corner of
the of the room on the floor you know
like a plug hole yeah
um and if you wanted a wee so there was
a bucket in the room and if you wanted
to wait there was no
partition or curtain or it was as open
as this studio is
so if you wanted a way you did away in
the bucket and then you just poured the
bucket down the hole if you wanted a poo
then you put a bag in the bucket and you
did a poo then you had to tie the bag up
tie it to the gate and you know wait for
one of the police officers to you know
take remove the bag that could be maybe
if they felt like it they'd do it
straight away if you called them maybe
it could be a few hours the yeah it was
it was horrendous
um and I was in there for
gosh
a couple of months I think I was in
there waiting just in a month yeah
yeah no food no like I I relied on
the prisoners in giving me food so a lot
of them were locals and their family
would come twice a day and bring them
food right so they bring breakfast and
they bring
um you know the evening meal
my consulate came to see me
kit was like the the day after I'd been
put in there the local consulate come to
see me and he bought me some
snacks some biscuits Club social they
were called some like just some crackers
and some magazines
um and he told me that he'd given some
money to the police to buy me some food
and maybe if I was lucky they would buy
me some food but they would most
probably keep the money for themselves
so I think they bought me some food for
a couple of days in a in a row and then
they said that you know there was no
more money
and I depended on scraps from what the
other prisoners had what their families
were bringing them so what would you
have done if they they hadn't given you
any just
survived off Club social biscuits or
wow yeah they're not gonna let you
starve in that the police probably would
but their actual other prisoners I mean
they're going to make sure they've got
their their film first but they're gonna
you know throw you a bone okay yeah wow
okay so a couple of months yeah and I
mean it sounds like it can't get much
worse but I think it did get worse
didn't it yeah yeah so what was the next
step after that so the next step was
prison
which at first was a relief like when I
was in the police station and the
Consular told me as well and again I
just I don't know why but I just didn't
believe anything that anybody was saying
and I think it was just too much for my
mind to comprehend like I'm just
suddenly being thrown all these Concepts
and ideas of of something that is
unimaginable for a for a British person
yes yeah and especially like now on TV
you see all these programs you know like
banged up abroad and you but at the time
you know 20 odd years ago these programs
weren't on TV so you didn't get uh
understand or see what goes on in
prisons all over the world even now like
because I agree with you there's all
those shows but even now there's a
slight
arrogance to being brought up in this
country where I'm sort of thinking but
didn't the concert say oh don't worry
I'm going to get you outside something
out I'm going to get you out was it
nothing like that no they told me from
the they told me right from the
beginning that I was going to get
sentenced to 10 years and they said
there was nothing they could do about it
they were brutally brutally honest and
clear so there's no help no nothing they
weren't like we can investigate some
Avenues they were just like this is
where they said that there was um some
countries had a repatriation agreement
yeah and America had a repatriation
agreement and Holland had a repatriation
agreement
um and but England didn't have a
repatriation agreement it was something
that was being negotiated but it was
something that had been being negotiated
for a long time that wasn't showing any
signs at all of any progress
and then he told me that there was
already a couple of
um British prisoners in the prison that
had already been there five years six
years and the thing is even though he's
telling me this the whole time I'd still
still think that I'm exempt from these
rules every day
I'm thinking that somebody's going to
come and get me out of there
and I think that's just how I what I had
to
do to
not not go into that whole of this my
life now yeah I think there was just so
much to try and take on board that my
brain was only able to kind of process
like one bit at a time yeah and it just
couldn't process everything yeah all at
once okay
um and I think I was just also in this
state of of shot you know because of the
conditions as well I think I'm just
trying to deal with that and the the
only way that I could get through that
was by telling my you know believing
that tomorrow I'd get taken out of there
because if I at that point thought that
that was going to be it for the next 10
years
um I couldn't have I don't think my
brain couldn't have coped
hey this is Ben Powell Jones the host of
extraordinary lives and we're just going
to take a quick break to talk about one
of this episode's sponsors better help
better help is an online therapy service
that matches you to professional
counselors I was provided with three
months free therapy through better help
I've been using it for a month now and
it's been brilliant I think sometimes we
get so caught up in ourselves and what
we're doing on a daily basis that we
don't actually spend time thinking about
what we actually need and if we're happy
in fact I've found the system really
easy to use definitely going to keep
signing on afterwards it's a personal
choice but I think sometimes we think
therapy needs to be for huge events and
actually I don't think that's the case
at all you can use it to talk through
different situations that you're in your
life starting a new job problems with
relationships and even if you're feeling
fine I've found personally that it's
sometimes good to top up every now and
again if you're interested in trying it
out you can head over to
www.betterhelp.com minutes with for a
discount that's betterhelp help.com
minutes with thanks and back to the show
Okay so let's move on to the prison then
yeah so San Antonio is that yeah San
Antonio
so I get there it's a mixed prison
it's men and women wow um it's probably
about 70 women there
and about 700 men oh God all all open
plan all integrating the there's a
women's section so
at night time were separated but the
gates were opened I don't know eight
o'clock in the morning or something and
then locked at like eight o'clock at
night so between eight in the morning
and eight at night it's just all freeing
it's a self-sufficient Community within
the perimeter of the walls and you can
do anything you want in there except
leave
it's it's literally like there's shops
there's stores there's restaurants
there's
um drugs there's alcohol there's parties
um and as I when I got to the prison I
saw these guys on the roof patrolling
the roof and they looked rough and they
had guns and they had no Tops on and
they had ripped clothes on ripped shorts
um you know toothless you know and they
just look they look like crackheads
which they were but I didn't know that
at the time
and I remember look at them I'm thinking
they look rough like I thought they were
you know yeah security like the guards
they look rough why aren't they why
aren't they wearing a uniform and how
can the how can the guards you know
they've had a tough shift
and um
they weren't guards they were they were
prisoners defending like their territory
their the prison was divided up into
like sections certain men's sections
because of gang Warfare like things that
are going on in the streets so they just
had guns yeah like all kinds of guns
from they had homemade guns that they'd
made themselves from like the metal beds
Choppers they were called they're about
that big then they had professional
rifles and they had a machine gun in
there and they had grenades and they had
any anything that they and that was
known and accepted but yeah there was a
there was a section like one section for
the men's side where they had the
Prisoners the male prisoners had
constructed their own gate now twice a
day the Guardia would come in and they'd
do a thing called numero which is where
they want to count everybody to check
that there's you know nobody's escapes
and everybody's there and they do it
headlights section by section now to get
into this specific men's section the
internal
um bihilantes
um had to get like permission from the
actual prisoners to get through like the
prisoners had to open the gate for them
to let them through and it was the same
with the Guardia the prisoners had to
open the gate to let the Guardia through
and when they came they would always
someone be shouting if it was the
National Guards coming in then the
prisoners would shake like aguiver de
Agua Verde which is green water so
anybody that was doing anything that
they shouldn't be doing in plain view of
the of the army had time to like you
know get rid of and hide their things
and if it was the Vigilantes and it
would be agua aguasul so you knew which
ones were were coming in the Vigilantes
did you say yeah what is that what
um they're there
so you've got like the internal screws
and then you've got the National Guards
that are all based around outside the
prison they've got Tower points so
there's always the tower Point's always
manned where they're you know looking at
what's going on and then they've got
like an office
um block outside
um and they come in they do the numero
they're the ones that are in charge of
like keeping the prisoners in line when
it kicks off it's a good idea that'll
come in and you know try and so it's
kind of like
as long as you're not kicking off and
it's not right just get on with it yeah
and were you scared when you got it I
mean it sounds absolutely terrifying
yeah
um
no I don't think I was again I think
it's just a shock thing do you feel
under threat
no like the the Venezuelan men are very
protective okay of the women okay that
the women are safe and sound and there's
no way that any of the guys could
violate any of the women okay because
they every men's section has got like a
gang leader and that's just completely
against the rules and if you did
something like that you'd get killed
like the men would get killed for it
there's a there's a hierarchy and and
you do what you're told there and if you
don't abide for the men if you don't
stick to those rules then there's
repercussions and there's just no way
that anything was this explained to you
by someone like that was in their audit
was it just something you came to
understand I kind of I started to just
figure out there was some things that
were explained to me
um but I just started to the longer I
was there I learned little bits more and
started to figure out like how things
went and how about like woman to woman
like was that did you feel fairly safe
there or were they threatening as a
group
um it was really intimidating it was
yeah it was when I first went in
it was really really intimidating and a
girl came and she's like grabbed my
suitcase and sort of like run off my
suitcase and it was um and it but it was
all kind of like a
a test really and fun and games for them
but when you're coming in and you're new
to this fireman it's yeah it's really
really scary and I think could just kind
of tried to
stay away from certain groups and
certain people and I just
process and watch what was going on and
yeah I mean crazy because all that and
then the language barrier as well must
have just been such a sensory overload
yeah yeah understand what's being
shouted at you I said yeah
um like it was a relief when I got to
the prison because I've been in this
tiny room for ages with just these women
with new form of stimulation or you know
diversity to the day or or anything so
when I got there you know it's this
massive prison you know you can walk
around freely there's guys there there's
music going on you know that it's
it's a relief to begin with to get there
and and until
you know guns start going off and people
start dying and you know where did you
see that yeah
okay can you tell us a little bit about
that yes
um
so I think the the very first morning
that I woke up I was woken at there was
a siren that went off it's like an air
raid siren and I thought at first that
it was like a morning Bell or something
to to get a
but then as the siren went off like lots
of the Venezuelan women uh
fry in and you can hear that they're in
distress
and then someone explains to me one of
the English guys explains to me that
what the siren is it means that
someone's been killed it means one of
the one of the prisoners it means that
something's gone on internally and that
one of the prisoners is is dead and been
killed by another prisoner and like all
the women that are distressed because
maybe it's their husband or you know
their partner or their brother or their
son or whatever so
I think at first I wasn't sure if I
believed them or not because again it
just sounds like an overwhelming concept
you know that this can can go on in
prison
um but but it does
and then
there was a time when
it was like it was like a wall that went
on for war a war it went on for three
days
and the the Guardia wouldn't even come
in so what like a gang war yeah so two
Rivals yeah between two rival sections
in the women's section right in the
middle of these rival sections and this
war it just went on relentlessly for
three days like non-stop so what was in
fist fighting or guns shooting there was
a grenade that went off it there's a fur
grenade and it blew up like this section
called them the maximum which is like
their maximum security is where
prisoners get put in where they can't
stay on either side like they've done
something wrong on that side and they've
done something wrong on that side and
they can't come out because people want
to kill them right so they're literally
just locked in all the time for their
own safety because they're gonna get
they're going to get killed so grenade
have been thrown in that I've been blown
up and then the two sides were just all
like they were on the roof shooting at
each other and then the one side like
right next right next to Earth they'd
made these massive holes in the wall
they were like they were the size of
doorways and they would bring in like
the guys that had been like shot and
killed they would kind of bring them
through our bit and take them to like
the main kind of office bit which was
right by the the female bent
but all the screws had locked themselves
in and the Guardia wouldn't come in
because you've got 700 men like killing
each other so the Guardia are just going
to wait until they've run out of
ammunition or they've killed each other
they're not going to put themselves at
risk they're just going to wait until
everybody runs out of so it's not like a
writer site like like people dying
Non-Stop and then the
the ambulances wouldn't come it was all
over the news it was on the TV and on
the news the ambulances wouldn't come in
to pick up the dead bodies because they
couldn't because there was no because
that's bullets flying every everywhere
so these body and then like the infirm
Maria
is full up with with bodies already so
these bodies are just left like outside
in this Courtyard under the Venezuelan
Sun for two three days
um Boston's Wars going on just
just decomposing motting Under the Sun
it was yeah it was how do you have any
idea of how many people got killed
during that period of time like how many
did you see a lot of bodies during those
three days I don't know I mean I think I
probably saw
I don't know I think I probably saw
about
six or seven dead bodies and then quite
a few injuries where people were being
carried through a you know kneecaps shot
and
God knows how many dead bodies on the
other you know that was just the one
side so I don't know how many won there
so we just kind of staying in your bit
for three days just like yeah head down
yeah totally just stay a night of the
staying out of the way yeah and then a
lot of the guys were trying to like hide
in our bit as well because it's this
kind of
safe not as involved with the yeah yeah
wow and then when the when the Guardia
finally got back in
what was that like like did they have to
retake control by force or was it more
like walking into just chaos and
everyone had given up by then well the
guardian didn't come in until everyone
had given up right they'd run out of
steam or run out of ammunition
when I have whatever drugs it was that
they were taking that was given the
thing to keep going
but there was punishment because the
Guardia want to be
they have to regain like you said some
kind of control or some kind of
um
facade yeah they have yes some kind of
control you know realistically they
haven't you know but they have to be
show that they've got some kind of power
so
um they got all the guys I felt so sorry
for them they got all the guys and
there's this massive massive Courtyard
and they made them all lay down like on
it was like tarmac Courtyard and they
made them all lay down from like in the
morning from I think it was like I don't
know 10 o'clock in the morning till
about five six o'clock in the evening
they just made them all lie on the
courtyard underneath the sun wow and all
the Guardia they had these massive like
swords but they were rounded edges they
weren't you know um not stubbing or no
yeah like buttons yeah just like huge
swords with these rounded edges and
um whenever any of the guys you know
start to try and like move and because
they were you know burning and the
Guardians like beating them with the
swords and then they lined some of them
up they lined them up against the wall
and made them drop their
um trousers down to their ankles and
were beating them like on their ass and
on the back of their legs and the back
of their knees and the guys would just
like dropping to the floor where they
were getting beaten by the swords
I mean it sounds unbelievably horrible
okay you've talked so far about
constantly talked about the fact that
you're able to I don't this isn't real
this is yeah I don't believe this was
there a point where you were like this
is 10 years now yeah how long to it was
that right yeah right yeah I think it
was um it was about a year
and it was
not long after that event I think where
I kind of realized like this
this is really happening and I've got a
10-year sentence and
can't
I can't do this
um
and I was riddled with drug addiction
again so I was smoking now you know I'd
got oh so could you get that yeah yeah I
was so smoking crack again you know as
much as and it was so cheap over there
as well and it sold all my stuff and you
know I was just really
where's Rock Bottom I don't think
there's anywhere lower for me there were
to know whether you know there was
nowhere look you know I'm I'm smoking
I've got a raging quack addiction you
know I'm separated from my daughter I'm
in a Venezuelan prison where people are
getting killed all around me where I
have to face the next 10 years of my
life and yeah I took an overdose
purposefully yeah right yeah totally
just kind of
I don't know what it was
um
there were these tablets that would go
in mind the jail
um and I can't remember what they were
called
um but okay but just of pills like to
have yeah right yeah and I just got my
hands on as on as many of them as as I
could thinking that
um
that that would do and that I could just
nail all of those and just never wake up
again and what happened I woke up okay
yeah I was so disappointed did you have
to go to some sort of Hospital area no
I'd just been left like I hadn't yeah
they just left me we will I was
unconscious yeah yeah I wasn't I wasn't
getting up for
um uh the the roll call or the number
call and but the guardian came in and
you know checked and I was still
breathing and
so they just left me to it yeah and then
I came round
um and I was just
bitterly disappointed that I'd come
around and had to
deal with this still but it was also
like it was a massive turning point for
me as well because I felt like
I should have died and I wanted to be
dead and
I wasn't dead
um so if that wasn't an option then I
was gonna have to
to deal with this and and
find a way to to get through it
um and I prayed I got on you know you
hear this a lot didn't you when people
would just get to this complete point of
desperation there's no hope left in the
world and you dig deep and you just find
this um
faith I think or you're just looking
you're so desperate for if you haven't
got faith I think you're so desperate
for it anything so just reach out for
for anything so
um yeah I was on my hands and knees
um praying like I've never prayed for
anything in my whole life you know just
like tears just streaming down my face
just asking the firm
some
help somehow like okay okay I've got to
be here for 10 years you've got to help
me out you know you've got to please
you've got to give me something to help
me because I can't do this and I can't
get through this like I'm like this I
kind of made the deal and it's packed
with this
higher power or whoever it was that I
was praying to like
you know look get me out of here it was
and it was the crack addiction again was
really consuming me and I really hated
myself for it
um and I kind of felt like if I can get
rid of the addiction then maybe I can
try and deal with everything else that's
going on but I just can't deal with it
all so help me with the addiction and
I'll deal with everything else
so I put in for a transfer
and got transferred out of there the the
next week
so to a better prison in Caracas on the
mainland it was a all women's prison
okay
um and
I I stuck to my side of the pact you
know I'd made this
deal I mean I know you can't really make
deals with but in my mind that's you
know I was like well you get me out of
here and please and wherever I get to I
won't take the drugs I know that they'll
be there but you know it's just too easy
here and I'm caught in this Loop now and
I need some help so please help me get
out of here and and I won't take the
drugs so I got transferred to this new
place
um and
it was just a lot more manageable I
didn't I stopped taking the drugs I
didn't look for the drugs at all there
was routine there there was no men there
there was you know not
there was still a little bit of violence
but you know nothing compared to there
was no guns and you know people getting
killed in front of you on a on a daily
basis there was
um workshops there was education there
was a waste and a bit and there was a
bit of you know structure something that
felt more like a society yeah so you'd
been in the
San Antonio yeah for one year is that
yeah and then you transferred yeah and
then how long was it in this new place
which was sounds a lot better but how
long was it before you started to
plan
a way out
well everybody always planned for you
know sure okay in the moment from any
prison anywhere in the world that you're
in anybody straight away is gonna
fantasize about escaping
so it didn't
quite start developing there
um I was only there for
six months and then I got transferred I
didn't put it in for a transfer I just
got moved on
from there to this other prison
um called
what was it called San Juan de lagunias
in a place called Merida which was
four hours away ish from the Colombian
border
and it was a mixed prison again
so I was dreading going there I thought
I thought it was going to be the same as
San Antonio
um
and
it wasn't the same but horrendous things
happened there still
um but it wasn't until I was there
that I started
seriously contemplating and thinking
about
how could I get out of there and was
that just because you were like I 10
years is too long like how can I shorten
that well I just saw it as a viable
option right like I could I could say
that it could actually be done like were
people escaping around you no no no okay
um but I could see that it could be more
than a than a fantasy okay
um because
people were having day releases in in
this prison okay you know people that
had completed a a certain amount of
their
um sentences were getting day release
and they were able to go in and out
every day
and I got involved with the prison guard
and romantically yeah right okay yeah we
fell in love with each other wow like
massively like I fell in love with him
and he fell in love with me he was from
Venezuela yeah he was Venezuelan and
could you communicate at that point yeah
I could speak Spanish by then oh so
you'd learn Spanish yeah I've been there
but when I met him I think I'd been in
prison for about
three years okay so my Spanish was it
was good enough to hold conversations
and communicate and you know get by
um so yes so we got into a relationship
with each other and
I got my day releases like I got to a
point in my sentence where
I could apply for them and I fought
really hard for them I paid a lot of
people off to get them I paid
Administration officers off in the
prison to sign the paperwork
um where are we getting the money to pay
I'd had some money sent over okay and
Jose the the prison guard right he was
giving me money all the time as well
right and he would give me all his wages
he was wow he was earning more money
illegitimately in the prison like than
he than his wages his wages was just the
I don't know like pocket money compared
to what he was actually earning doing
things for the prisoners bringing in
Contraband okay doing things for them
outside so he had quite a bit of money
so he funded your ability to pay off the
different officials he helped fund it he
helped yeah he helped fund it and he
knew people as well okay so
um and just to be clear and obviously uh
you know
it's a bit of a personal question but
you said you would do it you you'd
fallen in love with him you weren't
seeing him as a way of
yeah no I wasn't
um
I mean when we first
started talking to each other and you
know we we joked about you know helping
me escape
um
but no we really fell in love with each
other okay yeah Head Over Heels
yeah unlikeliest places I know
I know
um okay so you got the day release yeah
and then how did that how did the plan
start to form for how you could use that
so we were close like I said we were
quite close to the
to the Colombian border right and I knew
that all I had to do was get out of
Venezuela and I was kind of Home Free
you know I wasn't and if I got if I
tried to run away and stay in Venezuela
then I'm in trouble
but outside of Venezuela it's outside of
Venezuela and jurisdiction
um
so I thought if I can just
get to Colombia
and then so then the plan had to develop
from there and it was like yeah but then
what you're going to do in Colombia
it was like okay well from Colombia I
can get a plane to your rep I thought I
can't get a plane from Venezuela to
Europe because I could get recognized I
could be at the airport like the Guardia
they do they go on tour so
one moment they might be working in the
prison but then you know the next month
or something they might be working at an
airport or they could be working it like
they have stops everywhere you can't get
from like one town to another you can't
travel freely without going through like
Guardia stops so there was always this
risk that I could be a get be trying to
go through a stop because you're not
allowed outside your area either you
have day release but I'm not allowed to
leave media there so even just getting
to the Colombian border because I've got
a goose room
some of these stops yeah okay yeah still
a few stops to go through and
you know a way to try and to get there
like undercover but I couldn't go to
Caracas and get a plane from Caracas
because I'd get recognized instantly
because I had blonde hair and blue eyes
and any Guardia that's worked in any of
those prisons you know you get to know
the Guardia because they come in twice a
day you know and they get to know you by
you by your name and by your look and so
I just knew that trying to get out from
Venezuela was just not it was it was
just high risk
um
so I thought okay let's try and do it
going through Colombia
um and
I started to get into trouble in the in
the prison
because
I was taking the piss really by this
point and I was having this relationship
with this prison guard everybody knew in
the prison that we were having a
relationship and he'd been transferred
out of there once and transferred to go
and work in another prison because our
relationship would come out and then the
governor the prison that I was in lost
his job so he got his transfer back to
the pre to the prison that I was in
again so like all the staff knew like
some of them were on our side some of
them weren't on our side all the
prisoners knew I had day release I was
supposed to
go out during the day to work and then I
was supposed to come back in the night
time
um I wasn't going to work I'd had paid
somebody off to say that I had a job
there and I didn't I wasn't coming back
at night I was getting doctor's um
certificates to sign me off
um Jose was using his connections with
people inside the prison where he was
friends with the governor I was staying
out for two weeks at a time you know
yeah going out with the governor you
know because Jose was friends with the
governor you know the governor would
come and meet us and we'd take him out
and we'd get him drunk and then we'd ask
him to phone at the prison to say that I
didn't have to come back for the weekend
oh wow yeah and this went on for like
quite a few months and
um people started to get annoyed with it
right
um some of the guards the female guards
were getting fed up with their some of
the prisoners were getting fed up with
their because I was just taking the piss
really and why should I be able to do it
and everybody else couldn't do it so we
were like planning this escape and we
like we'd planned it a little bit more
further ahead
um and we suddenly got told
um that I was going to have my benefit
taken off me my day release I've got a
phone call and they were like they're
gonna take the day release off me
because of everything that was going on
we'd been stopped in time as well we'd
been in town
um and kind of Arrested
um because I was with Jose in time in
LaGuardia like got us the the prison had
like phoned up and said if they're seen
together you've got to get them and it
was like well you guys can't be together
um I got to back to the prison I tried
to get out in the morning they wouldn't
let me out that day I had to like appeal
to be able to get out so I got out I
think like the day after and it's like
we've got to go now like I'm not gonna
wow last like again
um so we had to bring everything forward
and then the day that it was planned for
there was like a storm of biblical
proportions
um and my Escape Route was blocked
like because all the cliffs there had
been like an avalanche and the Cliffs of
the bus couldn't get through because all
these Boulders were in the way so I'd
got off the bus and I tried to get
attacked soon oh see it's set off you'd
got on the bus and you'd set off yeah
yeah I'd go yeah I went in so it was
arranged that I was going to meet Jose
at the at the bus station yeah a place
called a heedom and from hido is where
like that was our last I needed to get
to a hedo and then from ajido I was
going to kukuta which is the Colombian
side okay of the border so
um it arranged to meet Jose we decided
to travel separately yeah because we
would be in monitor you know people they
were looking for us like traveling
together
so I'd got on the bus had been this
Avalanche and the bus couldn't get
through because of these bold airs
I'd got a taxi the taxi couldn't get
through the taxi took a different route
but then it only got so far because of
I think the river had like burst six
Banks and the taxi couldn't get through
him
I couldn't go back because it's not like
oh I can't go back I'll go back stay the
night and try again tomorrow
um because I knew if I went back I was I
wasn't gonna be let out again for a day
release that was it I was going to be in
there for another five years
so then I got another bus going another
route
and we got this River Crossing it's
supposed to be a road and again the
river could burst its banks and there
were Guardia everywhere and by this
point I'm not even supposed to be in
this area like I've I've gone out of
married dad which is way out of like the
the Jewish diction that on my day
release I'm supposed to be confined
within it says Guardia everywhere
because of this you know burst
Riverbanks and you know this storm
trying to like direct everybody and
um
someone this best and I can see like the
best doesn't want to go through there's
this
was a road but now it's a river but
there's all these four by fours like
going through and I'm watching them and
I can see that there is a path the
vehicles are taken and then like the
smaller cars aren't going through and
some people would be in turn around and
some people are being allowed to go
through the Guardia and the bus driver
he wasn't going to do it
I went up to him and just begged him to
like please like look you can do it I
was like look you can do it they can do
it they're going that way just go behind
that track and follow the route you take
in and like my life depended on it and I
think the best I ever messed up felt
like this girl's begging me this like
her life's depending on it and then like
everybody else on the bus then started
like everyone wants to get to their
destination maybe not as much as I do
but everybody wants to get to their
destination so then everybody else on
the bus is then like cheering the best
driver on so he's under like kind of
like quite a lot of immense peer
pressure from his um passengers as well
and uh you know I think by this one he
wants to be the hero as well and I'm
trying to have this conversation with
him like when there's guardio everywhere
um so he does he's decides that he's
gonna he's gonna go so we're going
through this path and the water's
filling up it's coming in the best like
the waters came in there through the
step in the best I'm there trying to
hide you know with my head down like
this and then you know going past all
these Guardia everywhere did you have
any sort of Disguise or was it just no
no no
okay head dying like this trying to hide
from the guardian
and um and yeah and we made it firm when
we made it through the other side like
the whole best just like burst into
glorious Applause yeah and the best
driver feels like you know he's a hero
and he saved the day and you know I'm
just a quivering wreck and see you know
like sweat pouring off me
and um yeah I made it to the to the bus
station where I don't know how he'd done
it where Jose was waiting for me and uh
he said that he'd been like because I
was I was late it was like four hours
late from our like Rendezvous point in
time
um and I didn't even know if he was
going to be there yeah if he had got
there if he was going to wait you know
what was he going to do where was he
going to think I am because we'd sold
our phones like we didn't have any phone
because we just wanted as much money as
we could get together was he gonna come
with you yeah he came with it he did he
did right he did yeah he did come with
me
um so we had no forms of communicating
with each other because we had no idea
that this massive storm was going to
happen it was simple it was like right
I'll leave this time you leave that time
we'll take separate routes meet you at
the bus station at you know 10 o'clock
in the morning and I didn't get there
till two o'clock in the afternoon she
must have been relieved to see him there
oh I didn't even know like I got there
and I was like is he even gonna be here
yeah
um and when I did see him it was just
like the most amazing feeling
um and then
he'd got there with no problems he'd
left like half an hour after me and just
got straight through
um and he was so lovely because I
remember and like I said to him like I
didn't know if you're going to be here
like how how long would you have waited
for he said he would have just waited
forever
so I don't know how long he would have
waited for but yeah so then
from there
we got
Taxi
to kukutta which is the Colombian side
of the border and can you just pass
through well we got a taxi with these
Mexicans that were we just shared this
taxi
um because there was different ways to
get to this place from the bus station
that was you know the burst or there was
a taxi so we met these Mexicans and
decided that our best bet
was to just like share a taxi with them
and just say that we were just going to
kukata but you have to go through the
checkpoint yeah the border control
um but
if you're a lot of times if you're just
going to kukata and back because people
are doing that every single day
um the
the Border people
don't stamp your passport
so did you have your passport yeah how
did you have it I got it off my Embassy
okay yeah when I got out for my day
release
um I phoned my British Embassy app and I
told them that I'd got day release and
that I wanted to get a job a paid job
but that to get a paid job I needed ID
and that the only idea that I had was
prison ID and that I didn't want to go
and apply for a paid job with prison ID
and could I have my passport
and I wonder if they knew what probably
I'm sure they probably had a suspicion
um
but they gave you it they gave me it
yeah okay yeah and they gave me my
passport okay so you made it to the
border yeah and because they thought you
were going in and back yeah well I just
kind of like
hid like kind of hid in the back seat of
the car like pretending to be asleep and
everyone else did the talking and they
were like oh it's just a you know
just go in there and bark and she can't
speak Spanish and they were just like oh
you know just just let us through like I
think there must have been um
light shining down on me with fever that
day you know um but there was
there was no other option yeah it had to
be successful
that there was no in my mind there was
failure was just not an option there was
no
for me there was only one outcome and
that outcome was going to be I was
getting out of there
and I didn't even enter my mind or that
it was ever going to be any other way
so we got through
and then
we went to
Bogota
to get the plane
Spain because the plan was we were going
to go to Spain
and then we got into so much [__] in
Bogota
because we didn't have the entry stamps
on the passport so when we were trying
to leave Bogota immigration like Hall
decept and separated us and interrogated
us wanting to know how we'd got into the
country and ironically they thought I
was smuggling drugs
I know hi
um and they like set stole my bags they
wanted to take me to a hospital to have
scans yeah like they knew something was
up because it was fishy because why
would you you know why haven't you got
these stamps on your passport you've got
this bizarre story that doesn't quite
make sense
um
so
I told we knew I knew we knew that there
was potentially going to be some issues
at the airport so we had some money
reserved by to deal with any potential
problems should we come across them and
we got to the airport really early
in so that there would be time to
actually deal with things so when they
said could they take me to the airport
I offered to pay for the taxi I was like
yep we can go to the airport
um can we go now and I'll pay for a taxi
because I know because I was used to how
things worked in Venezuela
um I kind of imagined that it would be
similar in Colombia and in Venezuela
when you're supposed to go to court
there was supposed to be a prison van
that took you from the police station to
court and a lot of the times it wasn't
available because the governor had spent
the money for fuel on whatever and you
know on on himself he just kept all the
money so if you wanted to go to court a
lot of the times if you had the money to
pay for a taxi instead of like the
prison van taking you you could go to
court in a taxi but the the guards would
have to come with you so
I said to them in the airport yeah let's
go to court um let's go to the hospital
yeah
um I'll pay for a taxi because you know
if I pay for a taxi can we go now
because if we go now then maybe there's
enough time to go to hospital or do the
things you'll see I haven't got any
drugs we can get a taxi back and there's
still time for me to to get the plane
so after a while they said that they
didn't need to go to hospital said that
they didn't think they weren't convinced
that I had anything inside me because I
was too eager to just get to to get
there and get back
um and they wanted to know what was
going on so in the end we cut we
confessed a little bit we just said look
yes there is something going on but it's
not drugs and it's nothing to do with
Colombia
and I just want to get home how much is
it going to cost to sort this out you've
checked me you've checked the suitcase
you've done your checks to see if I'm
you know there's anything going on with
me in Colombia and there's nothing the
only issue is because I haven't got the
stamp on the passport so how much is it
going to cost for you to ignore that and
let me get on the plane or put the stamp
on on my passport and there were two
immigration officers and we paid them
200 each and they let us get on the
plane to Madrid
yeah wow I know I thought you were going
to say more than that no
okay so you got to Madrid yeah and Jose
was still with you yeah
how long did you stay are you still
together how long did you stay together
for no we stayed together all together
we stayed together for about five five
and a half years we came to England
together things didn't work out the way
that we'd planned or how we'd expected
in Spain
so we came to England
um I got in contact with the foreign
Commonwealth office to find out what my
legal status was going to be which was
such a bizarre
um conversation and an interaction with
them because did you have to tell them
the truth did you have to say that I did
yeah they didn't even know I'd been gone
I'd been gone nine months I'd been in
Spain for nine months
um run out of money I hadn't got work I
was like right I wonder what the
situation is if I go back to to England
because I knew that in England I could
get support get money and get somewhere
to live
so I phoned up the foreign Commonwealth
office and said right okay what happens
if I come back to England yeah am I
gonna have to
serve the rest of my sentence in England
am I going to get sent back to Venezuela
like what's what's the deal here and
they didn't understand that I wasn't in
prison in Venezuela Venezuela hadn't
told them that I had left and so their
first reaction was well you can't come
back yet Natalie you've still got you
know four and a half five years left to
do on your sentence and the repatriation
agreement hasn't gone through like what
do you want about I said you do know
that I'm not in prison don't you and
that I've done a Renault and I'm not in
Venezuela and they had no idea yeah so
their first reaction was where are you
um and I said that's irrelevant so that
doesn't matter where I am just tell me
what's what's my legal status what's the
situation
so they got in contact with Venezuela
and Venezuela said that as long as I
didn't go back there for the duration of
my sentence they had no interest
in me being returned there because it
costs them money you know it costs them
a lot of money for me to be a prisoner
in their prison life never contributed
anything to their economy and the
British government does not give them
anything for my keep there so I'm just a
a drain on they're all ready limited
resources
and then as far as England was concerned
you know Venezuela hadn't requested that
I go to prison there and finish off my
sentence there and I hadn't committed a
crime in England so again to put me in
prison in England
for a crime I haven't committed which is
also a massive drain on their resources
um just doesn't make sense so I was free
to to just go back to England so
basically
you were told that as long as you didn't
go back to Venezuela for the next six
years or whatever it was yeah you were
free yeah both sides yeah that must have
felt pretty amazing yeah
um
it was an interesting Insight how laws
and politics work
[Music]
um
in a way that
most people would never you wouldn't
think no so did Jose come back to the UK
with you yeah so Jose came Jose came
back with me
and
he overstayed he wasn't even supposed to
be there at all and he didn't have any
visas or anything we we basically
blagged his way in and we got a boat
from Santander to I think it was
Plymouth or Portsmouth I can't remember
which one and we kind of blagged her
blogged him in through immigration
um which he wouldn't have been allowed
to do on his own I think it was just
because he was with me and I was British
and we were a couple and we had this you
know story ready for them
um and
then I think like reality like hitting
real life started to yeah to happen then
and
Jose really struggled because he
couldn't work
um and that was a big
thing
for him was to be able to provide and to
be able to be there the breadwinner
and after a couple of years I think it
was like maybe like three years we were
together in England
this really started to
um
create some issues for him you know it
was really kind of stripping away his
his identity
um and we wanted to have a child and he
wanted us to get married so we went to
try and get married and were told that
we couldn't get married because she
didn't have he needed to have like the
correct paperwork so then we tried to
get the paperwork but he can't get the
paperwork whilst in England has to be
you can only get that paperwork in the
country that you're that you're from
so
we agreed that he would go back to
Venezuela and apply for that paperwork
um and that he'd come back with the
correct paperwork and then with that
paperwork he'd be able to work we'd get
married and we could have this
family and
you know hopefully things would work out
better than they were at that time
um
but he went back and he got into loads
of trouble at Heathrow Airport because
he'd been in England by this point for
three years wow and he just had this
entry stamp on his passport that in no
Visa
um and they put this black mark on his
passport to say that he wasn't allowed
to enter England or Europe again for
five years oh wow and he went back to
Venezuela and and we appealed it he went
to the British Embassy and and we
appealed the the decision and um just
got turned down so then he can't come
back for five years I can't go back to
Venezuela
and it just
that we went our own I mean we still
speak okay yeah yeah we're still we're
still friends now and we still speak and
have affection for each other and
remember I mean it's an amazing story
you shared
so another character in your story was
your daughter
uh what happened there
so when I whilst I was away
my friend looked after her the same
friend oh wow that right from the very
beginning
um God that's amazing I know
um and she had her own stuff going on as
well in in her life
um she's a legend definitely she's a
Superhero real life superhero
um so my friend looked after her
and when I came back my daughter didn't
recognize me she didn't know who I who I
was
um and and then I told her my name and
um she asked me she said she asked me if
I was her mum
so I had to rebuild that that
relationship and
I was really lucky that my daughter
didn't Harbor she I think she was too
young really
um
to kind of understand what had been
going on and by that point she had lived
more of her life with my friend than she
had with me so when you're just talking
about your daughter there about how long
you were away from her how long was it
in total
four and a half years four and a half
years and she was about three when she
got to she was three and then she was I
was away from her four and a half years
yeah okay so we had to rebuild
um the relationship and it worked really
well with my friend it was a real
gradual process
um and it went really smoothly
so
I mean over the years it's we've had a
really quite a rocky relationship with
um you know our ups and downs and we
would
just trying to work through those and
process you know I have to like I said
earlier I've had to deal with and try
and you know what I've done the impact
that that had on her not just then but
even now the impact that that decision
that I made to go drug smuggling with
her how that still affects her to this
day so we're still working through that
but
um
you know we went out for a meal last
night in Cheltenham and I stayed around
our house tonight and she comes to visit
me where I live in Spain and
um we're just doing our best to move on
from that and I'm trying my hardest now
to be the best mother I can be to I can
never make up for all those years that I
was away for her from her I can't make
up for those mistakes that I made but
I'm just trying my best now to to do the
best that I can and be the best man that
I can to her now today and tomorrow
moving forwards
you understand and when you look back at
your life which has been very unusual I
mean as I know there's whole elements
that we didn't even get to go into and
talk about today but yeah
um it has been an incredible
unique extraordinary life what do you
think it's taught you what have you
learned
think one of the
biggest things that I've learned is to
never give up
um to to keep going and that life will
never throw anything at us that we're
not capable of of dealing with and that
maybe some of these challenges that we
go through uh for a reason and now I
want to try and
use my experiences
um
to help other people and to I think like
I kind of have a message to people
that's like you know what no matter what
you're going through like I really feel
like I have been like rock bottom
everybody has their own version of Rock
Bottom
um and just all those people that are
there what bottom I just want to say
like don't give up you know and and
believe in yourself and it doesn't
matter how many times you [__] up like
don't think that all I've messed up
three times four times don't write
yourself off just keep picking yourself
up and keep going and it will all come
good and then all those things that have
happened one day it will just all
suddenly click into place and make sense
that they've happened for a reason and
that you can learn lessons from them and
then use those lessons to be a better
person and a better version of yourself
it's a great message to come out from a
very difficult start
um look it's been brilliant talking to
you when you tell your story so okay
engagingly
um thank you so much for your time thank
you
so they're they're all attacking and
basically the guy with the walkie-talkie
was the one that was telling them what
was it orchestrating that right and it's
quite hard as a sniper to keep your mind
straight because you you're watching
people get injured you're watching
people die on the battlefield and you've
got to keep your composure